or la peau casimir par six au casimir
par là ont vraiment un monsieur du snob
françois le facteur et julie commence à
m'agacer sérieusement avec l'euro
casimir c'est bien simple si j'avais des
oreilles ils m'ont les s offrait
non mais si encore il le disait
correctement alors on casimir mais c'est
toujours au casimiro casimir et parfois
même c'est ça on casimir or vaut
vraiment un mais mes bêtises mérite
quand même mieux que ça non c'est vexant
au monde d'ailleurs ça ne va pas se
passer comme ça je vais de ce pas voir
transformer de feu pas là plutôt je vais
lui à lui dire ce que j'en pense moi de
seo casimir en trois fois
casimir comment était mal je voudrais
savoir pourquoi chaque fois que nous
quittons nos amis tu dis oh casimir
d'une façon aussi ridicule parce que ça
se réalise aussi souvent que ça au nom
tous les jours même pas tu exagères
cette année beaucoup c'est surtout la
façon dont vous le dites qui m'ennuie
alors je voudrais que dès à présent vous
vous entraîniez à prononcer correctement
blé aux tats-unis rats allez au revoir
françois revoir casimir aux
caisses et 1000 ou quasiment en effet je
le dis très très mal
[Musique]
hop là
encore aller encore allez allez allez
alors à paris deux fois en vous
concentrant sanitaires non mademoiselle
julie j'en peux plus je me tais moi je
dirais même la corde à sauter c'est très
bon pour le son
je n'ai plus mon souffle de 20 ans de
suisse nomes et bien justement il faut
le retrouver
s'il vous plaît vous en prie arrêtez un
peu de martyriser ce pauvre amy 7% bien
merci françois merci vous vous êtes mon
s'ouvre je vous en prie beaucoup mes
amis asseyez-vous il faut que ce
soit on avait l'air bien préoccupé
qu'arrive-t-il que se passe-t-il
casimir est furieux de la façon dont
nous disons aux casimir nous disons si
souvent que ça je pense qu'il faut
prendre en considération la réflexion de
casimir nous devons essayer de lui
donner des eaux casimir qui soit plus
dignes de lit très bien monsieur snob
comment ce sont mes chers amis si vous
le voulez bien par le commencement dac
pourquoi pourquoi ils ont aussi souvent
au
quasi mire
pourquoi
des gens je réfléchis me concentre
gens réfléchissent à leur facteur qu'en
dites vous eh bien eh bien eh bien eh
bien je ne vois rien je suis dans le
temps au brouillard dans un nuage je
suis totalement dans le ton dans le
brouillard
julie s'il te plaît wahaha
et bien moi je dis aux casimir quand
casimir me laisse sans voix
à voir pardon moi j'ai un joli mais
enfin si vous êtes sans voix vous ne
pouvez pas dire aux kazemi me voyez on
fait bien c'est une façon de parler ap
essayons d'y voir un peu plus clair non
c'est bon d'en haut casimir il y a deux
mots oui et le premier justement ces
justes noces au dos h là est une
interjection qui
représente un étonnement ou
monsieur dustan passage je vous savez
instruits je ne savais pas cultiver à ce
point pourtant c'est un fait reconnu par
tout le monde c'est d'une grande culture
et ensuite le nom propre cas ziggy
alors à mon avis y voyez vous un bleu
pardon monsieur hamon noble avis cela
fait plus modeste plus discret plus
simple oui humble avis fait si vous
voulez vous donc à mon humble avis voilà
nous disons aux casimir suivie d'un
point d'exclamation eurent exprimé leur
étonnement devant une nouvelle bêtise
fait par casimir pas mal
et selon la bêtise fait par casimir
niggli son et lumière différente
o o casimir sous-entendu
sous-entendu à casimir qu'elle n'y vont
que tu fais sous-entendus oui enfin
enfin en france assume j'entends du site
entendent inattendue tandis que ce
sous-entendu ce qu'on va bien sûr
entendre oui mais en attendant casimir
non sous-entend rien du tout puisqu'il
trouve que nous disons mal aux catimini
pas si facile que ça et oui car nous
avons choisi là difficulté mes très
chers amis avec ceux auxquels finir toi
sur outils encore on avait dit je ne
sais pas à moi à eux à
casimir oui par exemple ou
non
ou alors
casimir oui
voilà ou alors carrément une quasi mines
casimir
abri alors là je reconnais ça aurait été
bien plus différents et surtout beaucoup
plus facile ah oui mais voilà nous avons
choisi le plus difficile il ne faut pas
rêver nous avons choisi au caddie au
quasi muet casimiro kazemi
n'ayez pas peur ce n'est pas moi
vous voyez quand vous voulez ce n'est
pas si mal que ça
aussi
[Musique]